let's start in cleveland where
fans were drinking after the game last
night not to celebrate the outcome first
time on sunday night football
for the browns since 2008 a lot of
anticipation they had lost at home by 30
points in week one but you know what
they were competitive
it looked good they had a chance they
were down at the goal line with 43
seconds left first in goal
and three straight passes setting up the
fourth down play with another pass chris
freddie kitchens admitted after the game
he should have run the ball down there
and he shouldn't have run the ball on
that fourth and nine play earlier in the
quarter when they went with a draw play
right look if it works you're a genius
yes when it gains two yards you're an
idiot yeah and he doesn't have the pelts
on the wall right to justify doing
something outside the box like that and
you know he he was very candid last
night in his post-game press conference
and he was going to take his lumps and
he did
and uh
we don't know what kind of a coach he's
going to be no and i think i think last
night he was a guy who's a little bit
over his skis yeah well i you know again
i think their whole team is a little
over their skis to a to a degree i mean
the rams you know they're used to that
setting that environment they're a
battle-tested football team well you
know whether we like it or not they find
ways to win ugly games too even when it
you know even when it is a 20 to 13 13
10 type of game but i mean to freddie
kitchens hey um yes first off i would
have loved to have seen him run the ball
down there i mean running the ball was
kind of the theme of their night you
mentioned it a fourth and nine yeah that
was kind of a bonehead call there it's
one thing to run the ball on fourth and
four fourth and five and you think you
might catch them but nine yards that's a
little much the play calling uh you know
in the red zone certainly a little
questionable especially in the night
when we saw them not being able to throw
the ball really consistently well all
night long
and then of course i think the biggest
reason they could never get in a rhythm
in the passing game
is because of number 56 and number 99 i
mean the the rams you know the browns we
worried about their o-line and it kind
of showed their real issues against an
elite defensive line last night where uh
yes they had to call the game to protect
their o-line because aaron donald and
dante fowler are going to make a mess of
things yeah the f up the play statistic
uh running wild last night for donald
and fowler and i i can't help but wonder
that sequence at the end of the game
first and goal from from uh
about the four of the five six yard line
did freddie kitchens not run there
because he's thinking about i already
burned myself
stupid so i'm not gonna run it down here
we weren't able to execute it because
it's never the play call it's the
execution yeah it was a good play call
we just executed it poorly so i'm not
going to trust my running game in this
spot because timeouts weren't the issue
no they could have run it uh just just
to take a shot there
when when you know people are expecting
a pass and uh it just it's confusing to
me why we didn't see them run it one
time and he admitted he should have at
least run it yeah one time in that yeah
no that they should have it just you
know again i think this is an offense
that's trying to find their way you know
and and even last night well the thing
that jumps out to me again unlike the
jet game it was a defensive game plan
for the rams that the this is something
i wonder about the browns are they a
little too big play oriented because
they didn't let them have the big play
last night for the most part it looked
like they kind of played zone coverage
we're going to keep o'dell in front of
us we're going to keep jarvis landry in
front of us do you have enough cue ways
and you know consistent surgical ways in
the past game to get five yards eight
yards fi to where all of a sudden okay
we do need to play man-to-man we do need
to change our game plan brown's offense
never made the rams uncomfortable last
night i think that's the one thing that
jumped out to me wade phillips got to
kind of stick with his game plan
throughout the night and uh they kind of
hung tough and weathered the storm and
of course won the football game and part
of the challenge for baker mayfield and
and i don't want to harp on the whole
big 12 defense's stink yeah but they
stink but but when you are able at the
college level to just impose your will
and throw the ball and do what you want
to do and dance in the pocket throw it
down the field throw it down the field
throw it down the field and that's not
there yeah
can you harness that i'll take what
they're giving me you know when you're
used to being a gunslinger and all of a
sudden they're giving you a peashooter
you don't want that you want to be the
gunslinger i agree mike i mean i think
he is kind of finding his way there
that's why we've seen you know some some
dumb interceptions through the first few
weeks that are over aggressive uh i
think it's why we seem a little jumpy in
the pocket i mean we just showed a clip
on tv there i think it was a perfect
example one of the issues with baker
mayfield through the first three weeks
no pressure around him from time to time
and yet he's not sure because the first
guy is not open and he ends up panicking
in the pocket and moving and it leads to
more issues in general but yeah they're
i think as an offense finding their way
and they got to find ways just like we
talk about with any great offense right
they what's your thing what is your
thing that defenses have to go oh we
have to stop that maybe they just need
to find more ways to throw odell beckham
jr the ball and just go off of that you
know because that's an issue last night
too how do we not really get him
involved in the game a play here a play
there uh there they have to find what
works for them and i think they're kind
of in the process of still doing it get
him in the groove early because you
don't get him in
it's the way he used to be with randy
moss get him in the groove early feed
him early and have him engaged otherwise
maybe he checks out a little bit and uh
look it's gonna be a challenge for
freddie kitchens and after the game
baker mayfield got a little bit testy
with reporters when he was asked about
some of the decisions made by his head
coach here's mayfield
mean i know what you guys are going to
try and do is talk about the play
calling but
you know what that's why i said
execution's the most important thing you
know whatever
whatever we have called we got to do our
job
kind of like we were talking about
earlier execution fourth and nine good
play call bad execution you know baker
mayfield's in a tough spot he's he's
essentially admitted and he was
interviewed by mike tarico for football
night in america that you know he was a
freddie kitchen's guy right so you can't
criticize the coach that you wanted to
be the coach because you gave them the
seal of approval they could have had
kevin stefanski who's doing a pretty
good job calling an offense in minnesota
right now but they went with freddie
kitchens because baker mayfield was
comfortable with him but now we're
seeing freddie kitchens has got to grow
into this role understand the concept of
feeding odell beckham jr designing plays
that'll work for him having that one
thing that you do right and not just
this kind of for you know i we talk all
the time about defenses having the full
offseason to learn what a guy did and
how to counter it
and as the team you've got to anticipate
it like the chiefs are doing yeah right
the browns i don't feel like they're
anticipating what the defense is going
to take away and they're countering with
something else and as a result we're
seeing as you said baker mayfield seemed
nervous and rattled yeah when his first
read isn't open because he doesn't know
you know he's not comfortable and i
don't i don't want to bash baker
mayfield here no yeah you know but
but you've as a team you've got to be
able to bust through the ceiling that a
defense has put over you and and we've
not seen them done that again do that
against the titans or the rams in the
first three weeks no it's just been a
series of like the first three weeks of
the year have been a series of just
really big plays almost really that's
the way i look at it it's been you know
oh yeah we scored a ton you know we
scored a touchdown we scored some points
but it's always a huge play it's not a
lot of like oh eight plays really well
put together drive gosh it was a handful
of runs and you know some pinpoint
passing with some great schematics that
got guys wide open we're not seeing that
like they're right the jets game oh we
saw you know odell beckham jr take off
from whatever but in between we saw a
lot of
okay that's good oh that's not so good
so they are they're a work in progress
they're a young team they're not battle
tested they had some injuries last night
uh and they played a team that is
clearly one of the better teams in all
of football in the rams you know as you
were doing a little sound effects thing
i felt very bad for whoever has to do
closed captioning
[Laughter]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports